fais pas mon vocabulaire c'est pas ma
façon de m'exprimer mais j'entends dans
cette ce mot d'ordre qu'il y a tout
simplement une aspiration au
renouvellement
il faut l'entendre comme tel c'est à
dire que l'exaspération que nous
ressentons que ressentent la majorité de
nos concitoyens en écoutant la radio la
télé aujourd'hui c'est quand même qu'on
en a ras-le-bol de ce qu'on appelle le
système d'ailleurs le terme lui-même
très à la mode et fait beaucoup débat
donc on en a marre a employé le mot de
dégagisme dégagisme est ce que ce n'est
pas un monde dangereux
je n'aime pas ce terme je voulais dit
c'est en tout cas c'est pas mon terme
mais je veux entendre ce que ce terme
exprime du point de vue des militants
est ce que cela exprime c'est qu'il faut
passer nouvelle république qu'on a un
besoin de renouvellement que nous
proposons cette nouvelle république avec
des mesures fortes qui sont aussi bien
le statut de l'élu le non cumul des
mandats la proportionnelle la
reconnaissance n'est pas ce terme est
est ce que il a le droit de l'employé
aujourd'hui 10 oriane c'est quelque
chose de dangereux qui fait peur qui
fait un peu populiste à 17 heures un
show sans cette idée de la part d'un
candidat à la présidence de la
république d'employés en termes comme ça
dégagisme je pense qu'il fait référence
à des mouvements qui ont existé ailleurs
à travers le monde et qui qui appellent
en effet un changement de régime
politique avant c'est que les français
sont prêts à un discours aussi radical
je pense que les français sont en
attente d'un discours un peu radical et
d'un changement véritable visage le cou
et les deux mouvements ok je mets
d'ailleurs c'est quoi
donald trump oui face à donald trump non
je pensais pas à donald trump pour ça
que je pensais au prince
maintenant je pense au printemps arabe
je pense qu'à ce qui s'est passé aussi
en amérique latine face ce sont des
modernes ce qui s'est passé autour d'eux
des indignés en espagne vous avez à
travers le monde
un mouvement assez fort qui prend
évidemment qui a quitté touchera pas la
même question qui touche la france mais
qui n'est pas le même et qui n'a pas les
formes d'expression suivant les
histoires des pays des continents mais
qui atteint l'europe
aujourd'hui on l'a vu avec la grèce on
l'a vu avec l'espagne et en france il ya
quelque chose de cette de cette nature
là est le problème c'est que cette
demande de radicalité
cette exaspération cette colère est ce
qu'elle va aller du côté d'une réponse à
la donald trump du repli de la
xénophobie de l'autoritarisme
ou est ce qu'elles valent
et du côté de l'émancipation du partage
des richesses et d'une nouvelle
république
c'est là que je joue et c'est ça le
débat se jouer sur ce discours jouer sus
trémosa ne renforce pas le sentiment de
tous pourris et donc chez nous renforcer
le front national écoutez ce que ce que
je crois c'est que nous devons répondre
aux besoins de changement véritable
il ya eu des alternances depuis trente
ans un coup la mouche un coup à droite
un coup à gauche un coup à droite les
français en tout cas moi je les entends
dans ma circonscription mais je crois
que vous les entendez peut-être
j'imagine j'espère de la même manière se
disent mais à quoi ça sert on a toujours
la même politique ça ne change pas il
faut que ça change moi c'est un mot que
j'entends très souvent il faut que ça
change
et si nous ne prenons pas la mesure de
cette exaspération alors oui le pire
peut advenir lesquels et c'est notre
responsabilité à gauche d'être à niveau
de ce besoin de changement et de
radicalité c'est quoi le mot radicalité
c'est prendre à la racine des problèmes